welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and the mandalorian has returned
with season two but
the big return that you probably know by
now since the episode has been out for
several days and this was widely
reported months ago the big return
is a boba pet the original trilogy
bounty hunter with too little screen
time and a death so
unceremonious that the leading head
cannon is that the character had to have
been
drunk i'm not kidding blame it on too
much of jabba's spatuka
i forget the point i forgot a boy
and returning is not just boba fett's
armor worn in this episode by cobb bath
timid the ole fans marshall character
from the aftermath books
but the actual dude in the flesh played
by tamora morrison who played jango fett
in attack of the clones the source
donator from which all the camino clones
including boba fett were cloned from
boba fett's possible survival from the
sarlacc has been a mystery speculated on
by pretty much every star wars die hard
over the decades including patent oswald
the gloved
mandalorian armor gauntlet of boba fett
grabs onto the sand outside the sarlacc
pit but now that this is
legit on-screen cannon we are still not
satisfied
we never are we have follow-ups
and if you have been watching carefully
there are more than enough clues
telling us how boba fett survived what
he has been up to
and what he is doing next spoiler
warning in case any of the speculation
ends up being right and ruins your life
okay so first off how did boba fett
survive
one that does not simply walk out of a
sarlacc as c threepio explained when
translating javid's death sentence
you will therefore be taken to the dune
sea and cast to the pit of kharkum
the nesting place of the all-powerful
sarlacc doesn't sound so bad
in his belly you will find a new
definition of pain and suffering
as you are slowly digested over a
thousand years
[Music]
and while fighting luke khan and chewie
on the skiff boba fett was sticking out
when han blindly knocked his jet pack
causing him to bottle rocket into
jabba's barge and fall into the sarlacc
but this new episode of the mandalorian
gave us an answer to boba fett's escape
by making the even larger crate dragon
take up residence in an abandoned
sarlacc pit
there's no such thing as an abandoned
store like pit
there is if you eat the sarlacc ah yes
to paraphrase the great jedi there is
always a bigger
sand monster and one of the surprise
features of this crate dragon was its
ability to spew acid to dissolve its
enemies
it's abused acid now it's fuse acid now
according to mendo that acid must be
capable of dissolving and digesting a
sarlacc but
when mando himself gets swallowed by the
crate dragon along with that boom bantha
that acid does not dissolve his best
scar armor
you can see it smeared all over the best
guard but it does not appear to be
burning it away
so for you visual learners sarlacc eats
boba
sarlak's slow working digestive juices
gets started on boba but then
great dragon eats sarlacc dissolves the
sarlacc cutting out the food chain
middleman
so that boba his mandalorian armor
immune to the crate acid
can get puked up to freedom just like
mando did now canonically boba fett's
armor is supposed to be made of dura
steel
a different alloy than vesgar but in
cobb vance flashback you can see clearly
that bova's armor deflects a blaster
bolt
same as mando's best guard armor always
can so it wouldn't surprise me if they
end up retconning boba fett's armor to
be
best gar or suggest it is just as strong
as bhaskar even if dragon acid can leak
in and burn your hair off but before we
continue whether you're a well-known
baldy like boba fett
for thanos it's easy to be a grouch when
you're losing your hair it can be a
bummer apparently two out of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they are 35
years old well with
keeps it is easier and more affordable
to get treatment for your hair loss and
help you keep the hair that you have by
the way thank you to keeps for
sponsoring this video
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there but
at half the cost of your local pharmacy
and you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you can do it all from the
comfort of your own home
you just meet with the doctor online and
they ship the treatment right to
you every three months so you don't have
to wait in line at that pharmacy
find out why keep says more 5 star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly 100 000 men trust keeps for their
hair loss prevention medication so if
you are noticing that you're losing your
hair
do something about it for a limited time
go to keeps.com
new rockstars or click on the link in
the description to receive
50 off your first order okay so if that
is
indeed the explanation for how boba fett
survived what happened then
why is boba fett no longer wearing his
armor this is the bigger mystery asked
by
christopher voss hey no relation i don't
think either way i am denying paternity
theory
as to how boba fett was separated from
his armor chris actually was able to
include that shout out after getting our
exclusive this is the way shirt from the
new rockstars merch store you can do at
newrockstarsmerch.com
anyway there are a few theories to this
one is that boba fett's escape from
two turducken layers exhausted him so
much that he just passed out in the dune
sea where he was discovered by jawas who
stole the armor from his body if you
look closely at that armor the green
paint has been corroded off just like
there's some scarring on boba fett's
face he went through a lot
and there was a metal patch added to the
jet pack to repair the spot that han
solo smashed it on the skiff now boba
could have repaired that himself but i
think it's more likely that the jawas
welded that on
another theory is that boba fett as a
contractor for the empire
might want to change his identity and
kind of blend in on an anti-imperial
outer implant like tatooine but i am not
sure about that because think about it
now he would just look like every other
clone trooper enlisted for the empire so
that wouldn't help the other explanation
that i kind of like is that boba fett
could have voluntarily given up or sold
off his armor because one detail we
pointed out in the breakdown
is boba's tuscan rifle tuscan gaffy
stick
tuscan robes boba fett could be living
among the tuscan raiders
we know from the episode that the tuscan
raiders have this kind of ongoing deal
with the crate dragon where they try to
feed it ban the tributes to try to keep
it sleeping
perhaps during one of those feeding
sessions the great dragon
coughed up a boba hairball and then the
tuscan raiders whom we now understand
are actually way friendlier way more
hospitable as a people
could have taken in boba fett and
brought him back to his health and the
same way that
mando adopted the identity of his
rescuers boba fett could discover a
sense of kinship and
community with these folks folks who
ironically boba's former boss
slaughtered
like animals i hate them and now bubba
could live on masks like his tuscan
brothers
spiritually outgrowing the mandalorian
armor of his clone
papa so what is boba fett doing now he
does appear to be living disguised or
sincerely as a tuscan raider on tatooine
he might not be too eager to get his
armor back because at any point he could
have just snatched it from cop vanth
over the years but he didn't
and i assume that's for a reason so i
don't think we should jump to the
assumption that we're going to see a man
this season boba vs den if anything
they're going to have more in common and
be assets to each other especially if
bubba could say that he saw the error in
his ways and
stopped appropriating mandalorian armor
which mando would totally appreciate
and remember this season 2 premiere did
not give us answers about the big
tattooing mystery from season 1 the
identity of the mystery figure who came
upon phoenix shand
[Music]
i feel like if that was cobb man he
would have told us about it that chatty
cathy talked our ears off about his
backstory all of us are long
i think fenik shand may be with boba
fett
maybe with the other tusken raiders as
well recovering from her attack in
episode 5 last season
and her possible return this season
could explain what's next for boba fett
series producers dave filoni and john
favreau didn't just bring back boba fett
for fan service they took him out of his
famous armor
all to remind us of the face underneath
and where it came from
namely as a clone from kamino this
has to be important to the future of the
series dr pershing who study baby yoda
wore
a patch from kamino and this episode
pelimoto made a reference to beta yoda's
reproductive cycle in biology
you know if this thing ever divides or
buds i will gladly pay for the offspring
and trailer footage shows this kind of
rainy ocean planet that could be
moncalla or
camino so i believe that whenever mando
encounters boba fett this season the
reason for boba's live-action return
will be as a link to the primary star
wars history boba fett's camino and
origins which could be part of baby
oda's origin despite khawil's belief
that baby oda wasn't genetically
engineered and
boba's experience with vader and with
the jedi since he was there for django
and obi-wan kenobi's fight on kamino and
he was there for the massive jedi battle
and geonosis so i think boba fett
is gonna tell mando where to go next to
find jedi and to find entities involved
with genetic engineering in this
universe and i also have a bunch of
thoughts on how
obi-wan kenobi could play into this all
to set up his kenobi spin-off series
so you gotta check out my recent theory
video on that and another reminder to
check out our merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com for our custom
this is the way shirt and lots of other
great options you're gonna love
i'll be back on friday with tommy with
our wikileaks after show reaction to the
next episode
and my in-depth easter egg breakdown
coming out the following day on saturday
subscribe to rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me on ea boss
follow me rockstar thanks for watching
and uh one final reminder
please vote there's still time to save
this country
[Music]
you